[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer an New York denkt denkt meist an die
schicken Wolkenkratzer von Manhattan und
das große Geld der Wall Street heute
liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer reden wir
über das genaue Gegenteil davon und zwar
über heruntergekommene Häuser und
Klammer öffentliche Kassen es geht um
den sozialen wohnungsbauamweg Apple denn
was in New York passiert ist zeigt wie
eine einstmals gute Idee durch schlechte
Politik einfach den Bach runter ging
eine ganze Metropole und auch der Staat
haben in einigen Stadtteil New Yorks
gleichermaßen versagt am Ende dieses
Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen was
ich damit meine und wie es zu der Art
kollektiven Staatsversagen überhaupt
kommen kann wie ihr wisst ist nur Rock
City eine der teuersten Städte der Welt
die Durchschnittsmiete für ein Apartment
mit zwei Schlafzimmern beträgt derzeit
etwa
3200 Dollar im Monat und das ist noch
kein Vergleich zu Manhattan wo man sich
mittlerweile 5000 Dollar befindet
[Musik]
und ja wir sprechen hier über
Durchschnittspreise teilweise kann die
Miete noch viel höher liegen klar ist
auch dass die Gehälter in New York City
oft hoch sind aber eben nicht für alle
und längst nicht alle können sich solche
hohen Mieten überhaupt leisten
einkommensschwache mieter können auf
Hilfe vom Start bzw der Stadt hoffen man
nennt das in den USA erforderable
housing das sind zum Beispiel
Wohngegenden mit privaten Vermietern die
aber relativ günstige Mieten verlangen
denn diese Vermieter bekommen dafür zum
Beispiel Steuererleichterungen oder
sonstige Zuschüsse vom Staat oder der
Gemeinde finanziert wird das durch das
Department auf Hause eben development
den Ministerium für Wohnungsbau und
Stadtentwicklung eine weitere Kategorie
dieses sozialen Wohnungsbaus nennt sich
public housing in diesem Fall wurden die
einkommensschwachen Mieter in Wohnungen
die eine öffentliche Verwaltung gebaut
hat betreibt wartet und vermietet
[Musik]
das heißt ist zum Beispiel die Heizung
kaputt oder der Aufzug wird ein
öffentlicher Angestellter die Reparatur
organisieren ok was aber hat das nun
alles mit New York City zu tun nun hier
befindet sich die größte öffentliche
Wohnungsverwaltung des gesamten
nordamerikanischen Kontinents es handelt
sich um die New York City housing
autority besser bekannt unter ihrem
Akronym nycl ja genau Alan why Cage und
eigentlich war die Grundidee der envy
Cage eine sehr gute Menschen sicheren
und bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu geben die
anweiß die h.a wurde 1934 gegründet es
waren die Jahre der Great Depression der
Wirtschaftskrise nach den Börsencrash
von 1929 auch große Teile der damaligen
Mittelschicht rutschten Armut
viele New Yorker verloren ihre Häuser
und waren gezwungen in billigere
Wohnungen zu ziehen oder in
Wohngemeinschaften zu leben und dann kam
biorello Enrico lagardia zu jener Zeit
Bürgermeister der Stadt er gründete die
envy CIA Auftrag des Staates New York
man krempelt die Ärmel hoch und baute
massenhaft Wohnungen verwaltet wurde
alles von der New Yorker Stadtverwaltung
finanziert wurde das öffentliche
Bauprogramm von der US-Regierung und
natürlich von den Mieteinnahmen die man
sich daraus erhoffte die Initiative hat
damals gut angefangen aber heute ergibt
sich ein völlig anderes Bild es fehlt an
Geld aber nicht an Ghettos und
Verwahrlosung die sich in den damals
gebauten Gegnern bereit macht die
Wohnungen sind heute oft in einem
hundsmiserablen Zustand der öffentliche
Wohnungsbau in New York City hat einen
gewaltigen Absturz hinter sich vom Stolz
und Vorzeigeprojekt der Stadt hin zu
einem vollkommenen Desaster es ist die
Geschichte eines der größten Misserfolge
staatlich Gelenk des Sozialpolitik in
Amerika also lasst uns heute mal genau
beleuchten wie eine gute Sache
monumentalen Schiffbruch erlebt
[Musik]
ein mit nicht als guten Absichten
gepflasterter Weg
die 1930er Jahre waren die bogenzeit des
öffentlichen Wohnungsbaus in Amerika
praktisch täglich starteten Städte im
ganzen Land ähnliche öffentliche
Projekte um auf die Folgen der
Wirtschaftskrise zu reagieren aber in
New York drehte man sozusagen am größten
Rat und das ging folgendermaßen die New
Yorker housing ofarity erwartet
Immobilien und Grundstücke auf denen
wegen der Wirtschaftskrise nicht weiter
gebaut wurde als neuer Eigentümer und
Verwalter baute die hausigen autority
auf den ehemaligen pleitegrundstücken
Wohnungen und vermietete diese zu
relativ günstigen Preisen wir betonen
relativ günstig es hieß eben nicht
wohnen zum Nulltarif der ideale Mieter
kam damals aus der Mittelschicht und
genau auf den zielte das
Wohnungsbauprogramm auch ab auf Menschen
aus wirtschaftlich stabilen
Verhältnissen die nur jetzt während der
Krise eine harte Zeit durchmachen
[Musik]
die echte Unterschicht zog hier eher
nicht ein und schon gar nicht Menschen
ausproblematischen Verhältnissen das
ging in den folgenden Jahrzehnten so
weit dass man Ausschlusskriterien für
potenzielle Mieter auf Listen festhielt
das war die list of moral factors das
traf dann zum Beispiel Menschen mit man
würde heute sagen unregelmäßige
Erwerbsbiografie man überprüfte neue
Mieter auf psychische Probleme oder
Alkoholismus manche Listen schlossen
alleinerziehende Mütter aus oder sogar
jene die bislang keine Möbel hatten man
wollte durch solche Kriterien die
Sicherheit Gesundheit und Moral dieser
neuen Gemeinschaften bewahren
vergesst nicht dass wir hier von einer
äußerst konservativen und prüden Zeit
sprechen in der auch Rassismus ganz
normal war in den Wohnungen der
hausing-of- die lebten in den ersten
Jahrzehnten keine schwarzen oder
Angehörige anderer Minderheiten wie etwa
Asiaten doch der Ausschluss bestimmter
Menschen schuf neue Probleme denn wer
wirklich arm war zu Minderheiten gehörte
oder Probleme hatte lebte in den Ghettos
anderer Stadtteile die Lagen außerhalb
der von der anweisen verwaltenden
Gegenden dort gab es viel weniger Zugang
zu öffentlichen Diensten Unterstützung
gab es nur in Stadtteilen die als
respektabel galten die Folgen dieser
Ausgrenzung waren soziale Ablehnung
sekretation und Kriminalität die sich in
den Ghettos bereit machten tatsächlich
wird dies als einer der Gründe für die
schweren kriminalitäts- und
Drogenprobleme angesehen die in 1970er
und 80er Jahren in New York gastierten
[Musik]
aber obwohl das System viele Menschen
ausschloss machte es doch das Leben in
einer der Wohnung in der hausigen zu
etwas was man haben wollte es war für
viele Menschen erstrebenswert dort zu
wohnen schließlich handelt es sich um
Wohnkomplexe die damals in vielen Fällen
bessere Wohnbedingungen boten als viele
private Mittelklasse Häuser die
Wohnungen waren neu gut ausgestattet und
das Dienstleistungsangebot war äußerst
attraktiv zum Beispiel gab es eigene
Wartungsdienste Gesundheitsversorgung
Geschäfte Schulen und Sicherheitsdienste
es gab zuweilen Gärten und private
Parkplätze etwas sehr seltenes zu dieser
Zeit
zu meiner Zeit wahrnehmen Mitarbeiter
die besten sie hatten ihren Job sie
machten ihren Job sie waren qualifiziert
für ihren Job du hast einfach angerufen
und es wurde sofort repariert ihr Leiden
Wodka Bewohnerin der Queens Bridge
houses seit 1958 außerdem war das Geld
das vom bundkamer reichlich vorhanden so
konnten die Wohnanlagen in Schuss und
auf dem neuesten Stand gehalten werden
und das alles ohne die Mieter extra zur
Kasse zu bitten man wurde günstig durch
strenge Mietobergrenzen euer Boiler ist
kaputt gegangen kein Problem man rief an
und es wurde repariert der Wasserhahn
tropfte genau das gleiche sogar für den
neuen Anstrich der Wohnung kam jemand
jedes Problem wurde erledigt ein Leben
in Sorglosigkeit zu Spitzenzeiten gab es
17.000 Mitarbeiter die für die
Instandhaltung von hunderten
öffentlichen wohngebäudenten in New York
City zuständig waren die Anlagen hatten
sogar ihre eigene Polizei mit 2700
Beamten erst 1995 wurde diese in die
normale New Yorker Polizei integriert
[Musik]
die Lebensbedingungen in den
Stadtwohnungen waren bis in die 1960er
Jahre oft besser als wir den
Mittelschicht im privat vermieteten
Häusern wie ihr seht handelte es sich
gerade so um ein Vorbild öffentlichen
Wohnungsbau aus vollkommen neuem Niveau
und das alles spielte sich zu einer Zeit
ab als die housing of thirty bereits
Vermieter für rund eine halbe Million
New Yorker war doch Ende der 60er Jahre
änderte sich vieles es gab einen
verstärkten Zuzug von
einkommensschwachen Minderheiten die
weiße Mittelschicht zog ist jetzt in
noch bessere Gegenden ihr gestiegener
Wohlstand erlaubte das mittlerweile für
sie waren Krise und Great Depression
überwunden und 1968 vielen ganz viele
der Kriterien Weg nach denen man Mieter
auswählte hier machten Aktivisten Druck
aber auch die Bundesregierung die Folge
die Nachfrage nach den Wohnungen stieg
vor allem bei denen die bisher nicht
reinkommen
und auch der Stiel der neugebauten
Häuser veränderte sich statt niedriger
Blöcke mit großzügigen Grünflächen schuf
man nun große Wohntürme mit etwa 20
Stockwerken die konnten natürlich mehr
Menschen pro Fläche beherbergen wir alle
kennen die riesigen Bausünden die auch
hier in Europa seit 1970er Jahren das
Bild vieler Großstädte verhandeln
genauso war es damals auch in New York
City es ging nicht mehr um einen guten
Lebensstandard sondern nur um das
praktische Erfordernis viele Menschen
auf kleinster Fläche unterzubringen
[Musik]
heute sehen dass die Stadtplaner zum
Glück anders sind der Meinung dass das
soziale Wohnungsbau einer der 60er Jahre
einfach weitere Städte innerhalb New
Yorks geschaffen hat allerdings
isolierte und eben auch hässliche Städte
mit der Isolation kam es zu sozialer
Spaltung ein Entwicklung die in 1970er
Jahren in New York zu einer explosiven
Lage führen sollte aber wollt ihr wissen
wie sich der Sündenfall der hoising of
hurty dann weiterentwickelt hat dann
aufgepasst
als das System mit kippte
[Musik]
in den 1970er Jahren fehlte in den
sozialen Wohnviertel New Yorks ein
wichtiges Element zwischen den neuen und
jetzt viel größeren Wohneinheiten gab es
keinen Platz um Gewerbe anzusiedeln die
Folge die Gegenden waren von der
wirtschaftlichen Dynamik der restlichen
Stadt abgeschnitten in Kombination mit
der Marginalisierung oder Ausgrenzung
der Minderheiten die es dort legten kam
es zur Ghettoisierung Kriminalität und
Vandalismus waren an der Tagesordnung
man gab den Menschen dort also zwar
immer noch Unterkunft aber keine Arbeit
keine Qualifikationsmöglichkeiten vor
Ort und keine Verdienstmöglichkeiten
außer Sozialhilfe und wer dennoch Arbeit
fand zog dieser nach und damit weg aus
dem Gebäuden der hausing of the rating
es gab auch noch kein Konzept dafür wie
man mit Menschen umgeht die Probleme
haben oder aus völlig anderen
Kulturkreisen kommen als die
amerikanische weiße Mittelschicht man
verwarte einfach Unmengen von Menschen
unterschiedlicher Herkunft mit all ihren
Problemen in riesigen Wohnblöcken
isoliert von der eigentlichen Stadt und
das ist wie wir zum Beispiel auch aus
Frankreich kennen der direkte Nährboden
für jede Menge Probleme hier ein
Beispiel die Gegend in der
housingordserativ waren am stärksten von
der crack-academie in den 80er Jahren
betroffen es war üblich dass in den
Wohnungen gedealt und die Drogen auch
dort konsumiert wurden
[Musik]
aber das ist noch nicht alles der Start
reagierte und nach seiner extremen
lockerungspolitik ging er jetzt ins
andere Extrem über und er ließ jede
Menge neuer restriktive und strenger
Gesetze doch anstatt die Lage zu
verbessern führten diese zu noch mehr
Verwahrlosung des städtischen
Wohnungsbaus gegen Ende der 70er Jahre
okay aber was war eigentlich wirklich
passiert um das System des sozialen bzw
öffentlichen Wohnungsbaus in den USA ist
im Hause ein community development Act
gesetzlich geregelt es geht darum zum
Beispiel um die Zuschüsse für private
Vermieter die an einkommensschwache
Menschen vermieten und auch um die Höhe
der Finanzierung jeglicher öffentlicher
wohnungsentwicklung durch den
Bundesstaat
1978 wurde das Gesetz jedoch ergänzt das
housing choice voucherprogramm wurde
gestartet und damit änderte sich das
gesamte Modell des öffentlichen
Wohnungsbaus in den USA für den Bau und
die Verwaltung öffentlicher Wohnungen
durch eine Stadt gab es ab sofort kaum
noch Gelder stattdessen zu funktionierte
man verstärkt private Vermieter damit
diese günstige Wohnungen anbieten das
war vielleicht effizienter und billiger
für den Staat aber gleichzeitig auch
eine brutale Kürzung der Bundesmittel
für die New Yorker housing of the ready
diese besaß zwar immer noch alle ihre
Wohnungen für deren Instandhaltung aber
weil es einfach kein Geld mehr da und
die Folgen davon sind bis heute zu
spüren eine großer Teil der rund 2100
Gebäude der Stadtbehörde befinden sich
derzeit auf dritte Weltniveau und sind
teilweise auffällig es regnet rein weil
die Dächer undicht sind die Heizungen
fallen aus natürlich auch im Winter die
Fenster sind kaputt und Reparaturen
dauern Wochen oder gar Monate ein
Paradies für Schimmel aber gewiss nicht
für Menschen ganz zu schweigen von den
Gemeinschaftsräumen nicht einfach
verfallen man glaubt kaum dass es um die
reichste Stadt der führenden Wirtschaft
macht dieses Planeten geht wenn man
folgendes liest neulich hatten wir drei
Tage lang kein heißes Wasser also konnte
man nicht baden oder duschen und das
Problem ist heute ist es ist keinerlei
Ausgleich für den Mangel durch
Bundesmittel in Sicht
[Musik]
die New Yorker wohnungsbehörde bräuchte
schätzungsweise 40 Milliarden Dollar für
die Sanierung ihrer marodenwohnungen und
Häuser und die Rechnung wächst weiter es
gibt so eine wonach ist bis zum Jahr
2027 bei sage und schreibe 90% der
Wohneinheiten besser sein wird sie
abzureißen statt zu sanieren das ist
leider das Ergebnis vieler Jahrzehnte
öffentlichen Wohnungsbaus in New York
City am Ende führte er zur massenhaften
Verelendung 10.000 Menschen unsere
Verwahrlosung ganzer Stadtteile in einem
Sumpf aus Drogen Kriminalität und
Ausgrenzung und alles einfach nur weiß
ich die Politik ständig geändert hat von
einem Extrem ins andere schwankt und ist
kein Geld mehr für die Stadt und ihre
Häuser gab und natürlich stellt sich die
Frage gibt es eine Lösung ja die gibt es
hört zu
kann die New Yorker Hausen aus der
richtigen noch gerettet werden
trotz all dieser Probleme hat den New
Yorker wohnungsbehörde eine große Stärke
sie sitzt auf enormen Vermögenswerten
wir reden hier von
2462 Gebäuden und mehr als 10
Quadratkilometern Grundbesitz in einer
Stadt in der wir ihr wisst Immobilien
sehr teuer sind ihre große Schwäche aber
sind neben dem maroden Zustand der
Wohnungen zu niedrige Einnahmen
im Durchschnitt zahlen die Mieter der
Behörde nur etwa 542 Dollar Miete pro
Monat aber diese Einkünfte aus mieten
und Gebühren von Bewohnern denken nur
ein Drittel der Ausgaben der envy Cage
der Rest muss subventioniert werden
ein weiteres riesiges Problem ist zudem
dass viele Mieter ihre Miete einfach
nicht bezahlen wo also die 40 Milliarden
US-Dollar hernehmen um die Gebäude zu
sanieren wenn die laufenden Einnahmen
nur so dünn fließen
[Musik]
im Jahr 2015 kündigte der damalige
Bürgermeister bilde blasio einen
ambitionierten Plan an dieser nennt sich
Next Generation und hat drei Hauptziele
erstens wenigstens die gravierendsten
instandhaltungsmenge beheben zweitens
das Ungleichgewicht zwischen Einnahmen
und Ausgaben der wohnungsbehörde
verringern und drittens das Modell der
wohngutscheine Stärken bei letzterem
handelt es sich um einen Mietzuschuss
für Menschen mit wenig Einkommen es
nennt sich section eight voucherprogramm
die Session eight bezieht sich dabei auf
eine Passage im Gesetz zur wohnförderung
und was tat der New Yorker Bürgermeister
nun konkret für die Umsetzung seines
Plans nun hauptsächlich habt ihr blasio
die housing offered eV veröffentlicht
private Partnerschaften geöffnet das
geschah im Rahmen des landesweiten ARD
Programms ARD steht für rental
assistance Demonstration program es
handelt sich um eine Initiative der
obersten Wohnungsbau Behörde der USA
gegründet 2012 im Rahmen des Programms
gibt es Gelder für wohnungsbehörden um
deren Einnahmesituation zu verbessern
und es ermöglicht die Gebäude der
Nürnberger Behörde jetzt von privater
Hand verwalten zu lassen Management und
Instandhaltung werden also ausgelagert
und bis jetzt sehen die Ergebnisse gar
nicht so schlecht aus mittlerweile gibt
es in New York fast 15.500 private
betriebene Sozialwohnungen das sind etwa
9 Prozent der Gesamtzahl und das ist nur
der Anfang es soll in Zukunft insgesamt
62.000 Wohneinheiten privatgemischt
werden das ist rund ein Drittel der
Gesamtzahl der öffentlichen New Yorker
Wohnungen
[Musik]
aber wie genau funktioniert dieses neue
Modell nun die neue wohnbehörde wird
weiterhin der Eigentümer der Wohnungen
sein die schon erwähnten privaten
Verwalter aber kassieren jetzt die Miete
der Bewohner die privaten Verwalter
müssen sich dabei jedoch an gesetzlich
festgelegten Mietobergrenzen für
geförderte Wohnungen halten denn nach
wie vor reden wir hier von Menschen mit
geringen Einkommen die in den Wohnungen
der horsing offered Leben nur etwa
24.000 $ pro Jahr stehen einer
Durchschnittsfamilie in den dortigen
Wohneinheiten zur Verfügung und 42 % der
Bewohner haben überhaupt Arbeit der Rest
lebt daher von staatlicher Hilfe laut
dem Vorschriften der dürfen Mieter
jedoch maximal 30% ihres Einkommens an
die Zahlen und es gibt strenge
Kündigungsschutzregeln was sind jetzt
aber die daraus erwachsenen Vorteile für
die wohnbehörde in New York nun dieses
Outsourcing ermöglicht die umfassende
Renovierung ganzer Siedlungen ohne die
öffentlichen Ausgaben zu erhöhen und
bisher scheint es so als ob die Mieter
schon ein paar Verbesserungen bemerken
Bürgermeister der blasio kündigt an dass
62.000 anweis die HHL Wohnungen
umfassende Reparaturen erhalten werden
innovative öffentlich private
Partnerschaften werden fast 13
Milliarden Dollar für dringend benötigte
Reparaturen aufbringen die etwa 140.000
Bewohnern der Wohneinheiten werden alle
ihre Rechte als Bewohner von
Sozialwohnungen behalten eine Miete
zahlen die auf 30% ihres Einkommens
begrenzt ist und während der
Renovierungsarbeiten in ihrem Gebäuden
bleiben dürfen die Renovierung umfasst
neue Küchen und Bäder den Austausch und
Fenstern Aufzügen Heizkesseln und
Dächern sowie verbesserte
Gemeinschaftsbereiche kurz vor dem Ende
seiner letzten möglichen Amtszeit im
Jahr 2021 zugte blasio der Mitglieder
Demokratischen Partei ist das Fazit der
Magistrat hätte unter seiner Führung
einen Rekord bei der Schaffung
bezahlbaren Wohnraums aufgestellt und
seit 10 Jahresziel in nur 8 Jahren
erreicht eine halbe Million New Yorker
Bürger sein mit erschwinglichen
Wohnungen versorgt worden von denen fast
die Hälfte weniger als 42.000 Dollar pro
Jahr verdienten kritiker werfen ihn
jedoch vor dass während seiner Amts
trotz der Ausweitung der Ausgaben für
bezahlbaren Wohnraum sowohl die
Obdachlosigkeit als auch die
unerbittliche Mietbelastung insbesondere
für einkommensschwache Mieter gestiegen
wären denn der blasiusmaßnahmen hätten
ganz und gar nicht der Dynamik des
wohnungsbedarfs entsprochen und die in
Zusammenarbeit mit Investoren
geschaffenen Wohnungen sein für viele
Bewohner der schwachen Viertel noch
immer unerschwinglich es stellt sich
jedoch die Frage was denn eigentlich die
Alternative zu der Blasius Ansatz
gewesen wäre
denn im Ergebnis ist das vorherige
Modell der envy Cage als vollwertige
Verwalter von öffentlichen Wohneinheiten
ja vollkommen gescheitert unter dem
Blasius Aegide schaffte es die Behörde
immerhin sich zu einem erfolgreichen
Immobilieneigentümer zu verwandeln der
Konzession vergibt und eine
wettbewerbsorientiertes umfeldschaft das
soll dazu führen dass die privaten
Unternehmen die Wohnungen besser und
effizienter verwalten und in Schuss
halten können jeder konzentriert sich
eben darauf was er am besten kann und
wenn man es schafft das gegen den in New
York eben nicht weiter verfallen und zu
Brutstätten von Drogenhandel Gewalt und
Kriminalität werden hat man schon einen
ersten Schritt in eine bessere Zukunft
der Stadt gemacht aber vielleicht war
dies auch schon der zweite Schritt denn
der erste war das Scheitern des
öffentlichen Wohnungsbauprogramms
überhaupt zu erkennen und einzugestehen
das Beispiel der New Yorker housing
autority zeigt das gute Absichten durch
schlecht ausgeführte Politik oft ins
Desaster führen vor allem wenn man nur
den Staat und seine Verwaltung agieren
lässt ohne das Potenzial und die
Effizienz des privaten Sektors mit
einzubeziehen es lohnt sich also wachsam
zu sein wenn Behörden oder Politiker es
besonders gut meinen sich aber der
politische Wind dreht und einander
widerstrebende Ansätze und Philosophien
sich gegenseitig das wasserabgaben weil
dann keine von beiden nachhaltig
betrieben werden kann aber was meint ihr
was ist der beste Weg in modernen
Städten die Bildung von Ghettos zu
verhindern kann die öffentliche Hand
solche Probleme allein lösen soll man
alles den Markt überlassen oder ist eine
kluge und konstruktive Kombination bei
der Sphären die beste Lösung wie immer
sind wir schon darauf gespannt wie Ihr
unsere Swiss die Fragen clever Kontern
werdet ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat abonniert vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt es
bitte ein Like das mit einem Freund und
vergesst nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen um
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen denn
PayPal Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]
ja genau nycia
ja genau an ja genau night
ja genau
[Musik]